well the disingenuous media that's being
less and less taken seriously taking
less loss seriously it's it seems to me
that that trend which is a common trend
that's existed for the last few years of
these clique baby bullshit
articles and mislabelling people it's
gonna go away because your your your
perspective is not going to be
appreciated it's not going to be
respected if you if you're obviously
making disingenuous statements like that
and I think we're in this weird position
where it's very difficult to find real
journalism and real objective takes on
things that aren't flavored by their
ideology and everybody's trying to shape
everybody and they feel like it's their
obligation they feel there's many people
that write things that feel like it's
their obligation to change your
perspective on national subjects and
things that are important to us it's not
their obligation to just report what's
going on but also their obligation to
flavor things in a way that'll make one
side look favorable to the other yeah
well I'm very much in favor of
journalists revealing their biases I
think that the greatest lying media is
that objective journalism is a thing so
I'm conservative
you don't go to my site you'll get a
conservative spin on the news that's the
way it's gonna work and guess what CNN's
liberal and they are going to give you
the liberal spin on the news and that's
just the way this is going to work did
you see the video when the Mueller
report came out they look like somebody
got killed oh my god he's crazy
shouldn't you be happy if you guys
believed in Mueller everybody was like
Mueller is the fucking man he's gonna go
get Trump this guy is methodical he's
precise he's getting everything votive
candles with his face on it they could
like bird
they were pumped yeah and then he came
out and it was like well no collusion
Herbert's like well I guess that now to
cover up it's a wait what wait a minute
yeah maybe maybe the narrative has it
maybe the narrative has has trumped the
actual job you were supposed to do guys
well it's just so many people were so
convinced and there were so many people
that were making statements that in
retrospect are probably like you could
probably I mean I don't want to say I'm
not a litigious person but if I was a
guy like Donald Trump oh man yeah
there's so many people to sue is it it
was amazing I mean I remember I was on
Bill Maher
show and we were supposed to talk about
free speech stuff and like five minutes
before and he's like let's talk about
Russia as producer came in let's talk
about Russia and I was like okay fine
so we get on yeah this is like right
before they switch to talking for your
TV shows will they just tell you what
you have to talk God comes in with a
clipboard yeah it was it was a little
bit it was a little bit strange and we
got onstage and he's talking about Trump
Russia collusion and I said what I've
always said which is I'll wait for the
evidence to come out and then I will
make a decision as to whether Trump
Russia collusion was a thing and Bill
Maher's radical I know and Bill Maher
goes you don't you don't believe it was
a thing and I was like well I don't see
any evidence yet that it was a thing
like I see some evidence of attempts to
collude like Don jr.
I see some attempts of people trying to
get information but I don't see evidence
of like actual legal collusion and why
don't we just wait like you guys keep
wanting Muller to give is it like let's
just wait on it and Mark could not
believe that this was my perspective
right it was like he was like shocking
to him why should why should the
perspective I'm waiting for more
evidence be shocking to anyone when it
is obvious the evidence is not out like
why is that in any way controversial
it's but wildering to me well it's
because people have this need to let
everyone know that they're on the right
side and they want you to know that they
do believe in the collusion if you
disagree with that for whatever reason
you must either be a right-wing person a
trump supporter someone who's in denial
someone who doesn't look at the evidence
and you're a part of the problem yep but
the the real problem was jumping to
conclusions they're obviously seemed to
be some attempts there's there's
obviously some fuckery with that IRA
company that the the internet research
agency that is responsible for millions
of interactions with people online where
they pretended to be right different
supporters Rosa yes they caused conflict
like constant conflict in regards to
political opinion and that's all real
that was coordinated effort to try to
change people's opinions but how much
that had to do with Donald Trump how
much did he ask for you got no evidence
also I was always bewildered by this
theory like did you watch that campaign
that was not the most well coordinate
campaign it was chaos it was chaos I
mean I knew everybody who's in the
campaign like it was a it was a shit
show then the idea that they're sitting
there but they're but when the mask
comes off at night they call it Vladimir
Putin
then put together a point-by-point plan
on how they're going to swing this
particular precinct in rural in rural
Michigan what are you are you guys hi
what are you talking about
what like if you could attribute this to
any here's a good rule of thumb for
politics attribute everything to
stupidity unless you can prove malice
the real problem and this is something
that is very similar to what we were
talking about earlier when you say
something and you say it over and over
and over again and you say it with such
conviction and it becomes a giant part
of your news narrative and then that
something turns out to be horseshit yeah
you just massively empowered Trump
that's that's exactly right I said for a
long time that you know I'm not a big
fan of Trump's fake news stick because I
think he applies it too broadly I think
that whenever it's there's bad piece of
news like the fake names and it's like
well sometimes yes and sometimes no but
now that you just blew a two-year
narrative where he was clearly in
Putin's pocket how many people you think
and listen to the nuanced view of fake
news now and how many people do you
think are going to actually believe
Trump when he says that a bad piece of
news is legitimately a fake piece of
news yeah it empowers him in a in a
spectacular manner they made a giant
mistake oh yeah and they blew that they
blew this one in spectacular fashion and
people are still hanging in there well
all they had to do this is true for so
many people right now all you have to do
is not be crazy just stop it it was
talking about the possibility that Trump
has been a Russian asset since like 1987
or so is that I mean Andrew McCabe the
former FBI director was asked whether
Trump was legitimately a Russian asset
and he's like I don't know it's like
you're using the power of the
institution you used to run to spread
this nonsense and you got that from John
Brennan you got it from James clapper
these are all former heads of the
intelligence agencies it just makes me
think the intelligence agencies need to
be wildly curved back if these were the
heads of them I mean if like the heads
of the intelligence agencies are using
their platform to proclaim that they
have inside information about Trump that
turns out to be utter nonsense
I'm not sure these people should have
that much power to like is that what
he's saying or is he saying he doesn't
know he didn't say I don't know he was
saying like I have basically I expect
that Miller is going to indict as a
former intelligence professional I
expect that yeah there's a lot of that
it was
Adam Schiff doing the same thing it's
crazy now cuz like what do they do now
like how do they rebound from this if
this is there's no let's just say once
this is something you said for two years
right you've seen the compilation video
they've done them to rap music
so they're like they put a beat behind
it have you seen it now I know there's
some great ones some great companies
compilations of people saying possible
collusion possible collusion pop yeah
yeah and there's music that goes with it
and they just cut - possible collusion
with the Russians possible Russian
collusion yeah possible Russian
collusion it's yeah they blew it in a
major way yeah I mean there's plenty of
shit to complain about you didn't have
to go with that like the idea was that
he was a transit target rich environment
and he decided to go to he's a Russian
trader what looks like it's no way out
or something and was Kevin Costner's
what he could have ever beaten Hillary